Here we go. A lot of questions to go through first and make sure you chat in your questions as we go. If you think of something.
So again, reminder, you have questions between the Zoom calls. Look at the log posts on our regular website. Certainly utilize our member site. We're getting a number of people that is still haven't logged into the member site.
So you're missing out. There's a lot of good information there and we're giving you updates on there.
So the paper patient membership site is important for you to get on because that's where we'll share our announcements.
So if you worked with us two weeks ago last week, I was gone.
So you want to see the announcement that was gone last week.
But you'll also have seen the announcement that we have a new Zoom call on Mondays.
We didn't do it this week because obviously it was before I could July but every Monday at noon.
So you can ask questions through the Zoom again. Feel free to ask questions. And we'll look at those questions too. If she can answer them, she'll answer them. Her Zoom call.
If she feels like it's more appropriate for me to answer that question, she'll just push it over to me.
And I will try to answer it best in my ability on Wednesdays and calls. Now you have two Zoom calls.
So just to help save on your need to make personal appointments, save on finances for you.
We're trying to be best equipped with the tools that you need to continue with your protocol and continue having the best results that we hope to get.
So utilize the Zoom call on Mondays at noon. Those will also be recorded and those will also be posted on the membership site as well.
We've added a page on the membership site for genetic reviews to learn more about genetics.
And those are going to be done via Zoom call a specific time each week. If you have not had your genetic review, it will be on Thursdays at two.
Please do not jump on that Zoom call until we email you that your genetics are done. So that will let you know.
Let's jump to the questions. The newer program said test made me slightly sick on different days, but not a big deal. Let's talk about that a little bit.
There is a blog post, but our website, we go back to the website and you search good pain, bad pain. There's a blog post that I created a while back about different symptoms that one could have when they have a serious diagnosis.
Sometimes the symptoms of pain or discomfort can be a good symptom. And with change in the frequencies increasing pain, I would say that's most likely a very good symptom that is that it's helping your body kill that cancer.
We said, as I should mention that I still bleed while you're at 80 I drink a gallon of clean water daily. So I'm sure the blood is diluted becomes visible at the last few dribbles of your nation.
I wonder if the bleeding is because the cancer growth is pulling off the wall on the bladder. This first steps bladder cancer or because it's growing.
There's really no way to answer that question. Have you had other bladder cancer patients with similar symptoms during treatment is my question unknowable. And do I just trust our father's good and sovereign will through the unknown. Yes, there's there's a lot of truth to that.
And a godly perspective in this by this person, which is encouraging.
We don't know everything. We can make some speculations. Could the bleeding be cut be because the cancer is growing. Well, that is possible.
Typically a growing cancer is necessarily going to be a bleeding cancer. So I don't think that the bleeding would necessarily indicate that cancer is growing.
And the bleeding could mean the vessels are closer to the surface because your immune system is killing some of the cancer mass.
So I mean, I would think more of a encouragement to that we don't go forward.
We prayed through this. And again, trusting God's good and sovereign will for our lives.
Next question. Has anyone heard of harm and dependence for EMF protection? If so, what are your thoughts?
Personally, I've not heard of this brand. There are a lot of different brands out there.
Well, another patient brought up another brand to us that we may start carrying at our store.
We use the heat run brand right now. Some of these EMF protection things for phones and such and safe sleep protection for your phone.
I think it's the best protection for your phone. But there are lots of other brands out there. It's difficult to test them. So they referenced HRV, which is heart rate variability testing as proof of their efficacy.
I see heart rate variability testing referred to frequently when reading about energy medicine.
What are your thoughts on this test heart rate variability can measure a person's parasympathetic sympathetic balance heart rate variability is very good to there's different.
Different instruments out there. One's called heart math that the other doctor friend of night uses with some of his patients in office that you could help kind of train your brain to be more parasympathetic dominant calm anxiety and things.
There's some other tools out there that could help with that too.
Is there a test to determine bad or high estrogen levels. I think that's what's happening to my 50 year old husband. He seems to have those types of symptoms.
Would CDG estrogen be an option if so, how much so CDG estrogen is a dim product. It also has calcium deglutarate. It also has i3C in it. I think it's a good product certainly males can take that typically those are thought dim products are thought
to be used solely for females, which is totally incorrect males are exposed to just as many Zeno estrogens as women are so Zeno estrogens that you are exposed to from foods and plastics in your environment.
So environmental bad estrogens that you're exposed to males are exposed to just as many as females that effect if you're talking about foods exposures males are probably exposed to more because they tend to eat more so
males should and could take dim products as well so a dim product is a product that helps pull up bad estrogens. Is there a test to see where your estrogen levels are the Dutch test. This is the Dutch brand Dutch test but Dutch test really is an acronym for dried urine hormone test.
There are several labs that do the Dutch test. This is for precision labs. I think this gives you the nicest readout of any of the Dutch tests.
Doctors data has a Dutch test. The RT has a Dutch test. There's other dust Dutch test out there. But that is the best hormone test out there is a dried urine hormone test and it gives you read out of all your
or many, many of your estrogen and progesterone and testosterone hormones in their precursors and their intermediate metabolites of those hormones in that test and that is the way you would measure that.
We have these for sale on our site if you search Dutch test on our store you'll see that this little symbol in this test I think it's like three or 50 bucks or something like that. We said you the kid you just do it at home to urine test you do it at home send it into the lab comes the prestand envelope to go to the lab takes about a week or so to get back to very valuable test it can tell you if you have
a lot of bad estrogens or your low and progesterone or your high and testosterone or low and testosterone or whatever you're dealing with that could give you it could give you a real nice readout.
One of our breast cancer patients do that test. Have you heard of using curcumin IVs for breast cancer?
Yes, it's not just for breast cancer, there's people that do curcumin IVs for all sorts of cancers.
You could do curcumin IVs just for inflammation typically curcumin.
There's a lot of as an anti inflammatory it is a flavidoid and it does decrease inflammation it's one of the best things to decrease inflammation in the brain.
So people with post concussive syndrome taking high dose curcumin or in a curcumin IV can be very beneficial.
Also has hundreds of different studies showing its efficacy for cancers all sorts of cancers.
So using curcumin IVs for any type of cancer can be beneficial.
Curcumin in the forms that we see it in today is very absorbable though so to eat it in an IV isn't always necessary.
It is, you know, you do a curcumin IV, you know, from a cost perspective, it could cost you 150 dollars or something like that.
Some people are doing IVs and it's cost you a couple hundred dollars to go into IVs.
Well, you could buy a whole lot of bottles of curcumin for that.
So from a cost perspective, probably not.
If cost isn't a factor for you and you're getting IVs, vitamin Cs and things and they'll add curcumin for relatively inexpensive price, there could be benefit to it.
But I do remember, though, that all your nutrients, whether you're getting a bit IV, you're taking life of somal curcumin, or you're taking it in whatever form, you have, you get it into the bloodstream.
It has a half life in the bloodstream, all your nutrients have a half life, but I don't know off the top of my head what the half life of curcumin is.
It's going to dissipate, you know, shortly, so if you do a curcumin IV every Monday, let's say, by the next Monday, you have none in your bloodstream, maybe in a couple days, you have none in your bloodstream, maybe in a day, you have none in your bloodstream.
So if you're not also taking curcumin on a regular basis, this is why I tell you if you're, if you're taking three a per day of something where it's very true, you should split it up throughout the day as best you possibly can.
So because all these, if you take three of them, it's supposed to take three a day and you're taking them all at eight o'clock in the morning, you may have none in your bloodstream at five o'clock at night.
Well, let us not do any good from a cellular standpoint, because you have none circulated in your bloodstream at five o'clock at night, tell the next morning at eight o'clock in the morning, would you take them again?
So you want to spread out your supplements as best you can because of that thing, the idea that all supplements have a half-life in your bloodstream and then in your tissues.
For cost efficacy of doing curcumin IVs, then since you're certainly not doing them on a daily basis, you have to think through that.
CBD oil and breast cancer, same thing, CBD oil can be good for breast cancer and any cancer as well.
Could you please chat about DMSO added with frankincense applied topically?
That's the stop to the question right there.
So when you add DMSO dimethyl sulfoxide to anything, it will help drive it into the tissue.
So DMSO became big in the 70s as an anti-inflammatory that you could actually make at home with different household chemicals.
Now you can buy DMSO on Amazon.
It's a liquid.
It's like a water.
It's a sulfur compound.
So if you put DMSO on your skin, because you're, let's say on your knee, because you hurt your knee.
And you put like a teaspoon of DMSO and rub it on your knee, it you will soon taste like a garlicy taste in your mouth because of the sulfur.
It absorbs very quickly through your skin.
Be it a substance that absorbs very quickly through your skin.
It'll also bring with it anything that's on your skin.
So if you have like toxic lotion on your skin and you put DMSO over, you're going to drive toxic lotion into your skin.
So you always want to clean your skin that you're going to put DMSO on.
You don't want to have sun-ten lotion that's not good for you.
And you're driving it in with DMSO.
You're going to have sun-ten lotion that's not good for you.
And secondly, can you so using DMSO with frankincense or an essential oil will help drive that essential oil or anything you mix with frankincense with DMSO, or you put DMSO over that substance will drive it into the skin.
Sometimes DMSO is used as a driver.
No, DMSO by itself is an anti-inflammatory substance.
So that's why I said using it over D-paid.
But it can so putting it on your head for a brain tumor like glioblastoma can have some benefit whether it will absorb right through the skull or not.
It's because you have your skin, and then you have your lower dermal layers, and then you have your skull bone, and then you have your duromotor and piamotor.
And then you have the layers that cover the brain whether DMSO will help drive frankincense applied to the scalp through all those layers to the brain is questionable.
But certainly if it will help you absorb it into the blood vessels of the scalp, and that can help in many ways.
You don't think that it would actually, if you're not driving frankincense into the brain when you use DMSO, but you're certainly helping it drive into the vasculature underneath the skin there.
Alright, next question.
Oh, this was interesting, an idea for the store.
It'd be really helpful to have my protocol handy online, maybe either in a pop-up, where I can click on an item to see it in the store, then add it to my card, or with an option to click one button and put my entire protocol into my card, then I can tweak my order from there.
I thought that was a great idea.
I said there is no app out there that does that because we searched for after we saw this great idea.
We do have an app on our store where you can put things in an auto ship.
So that's called a subscription, so you can add your, if you do this one time, when you first get your protocol, you can add it to a subscription.
And then you could always change your subscription to, so let's say, oh, I need to take X amount of these a day, so I'll need X amount of these a month.
So I'll order two bottles a month of these, and then I need only these many amount of these.
I only need one bottle of those a month, so you could add it to a subscription on our store.
We've had that for quite some time, but that company is always improving that app.
Next question, I have all over my body aches every morning.
Feels like joy to muscle and bones, and it slowly goes away through the day, but not completely.
I've been off chemo for about a month, and the body aches have not gone away.
I used the right frequencies every day, but it was wondered if the body aches could be related to using the right.
I realized that there are other factors that could be contributed to these body aches, age, arthritis, food, supplements, the need to detox.
What do you suggest I focus on first and resolve these body aches?
So when you have something like this, I wouldn't think that this is necessarily a quote, good paid, like we talked about in that earlier slide, where it was very specific to the cancer site itself.
I would say this probably has very little to do with the right itself has more to do with needing to support detoxification pathways more than anything else.
There's too many possibilities to this without getting very specific to what this person is dealing with.
I would say this has has very little to do with arthritis, also, and maybe possibly probably doesn't have anything to do with food.
I would say more has to do with detoxification, and I would focus on detox pathways. I would think of trying to use that I am pro wave programs, make sure you're doing that.
I would say with just general achy joint muscle bones, just kind of feeling achy all over, you also want to think of magnesium too.
So maybe doing some magnesium baths would be helpful.
So that's what I would concentrate on food sensitivities can cause this you see this kind of joint muscle bone body ache fatigue tiredness with like gluten sensitivities quite coming to so that's a possibility too.
I have a family friend that had brain cancer and gave us information of fermented soy by Hayland soy health products. She is convinced that this drug her tumor.
It is fermented soybean oral nutritional beverages that are manufactured with a nitrogenation process scrolled organically in minerals so else and we use this product we have this on our store.
And this so understand I wrote about Hayland in my book stop by the cancer. I have several blog posts about Hayland and fermented soy in the difference from fermented soy to soy are like 180 degrees.
So fermented soy can have advantages especially with estrogen receptor positive cancers as fermented soy has been shown to dislodge the bad estrogens from the beta receptors from the estrogen beta receptor.
That's the problem with bad estrogens they attach to the estrogen beta receptors are used to be called the ale receptors and block and the estrogen beta receptors are an apoptotic receptor we did it stimulates apoptosis and then it's blocking apoptosis by attaching to that fermented soy has been shown to dislodge the bad estrogen from the estrogen beta estrogen beta receptor.
So we used to be able to get fermented soy at a loss it's called sadogastral a company stopped making that and Haaland has been around for years we've used them for a long time they're great it's a great product.
Oh second part of that question what are your thoughts of adjusting breast belt. I have seen studies and tweeted on this you know we haven't done much study of that I don't know the pros and cons of that.
Here's I had a cut off this question because the person's name was out here says his doctor is recommending the opt to device.
So the opt to device is a device it's actually a P E M F type device that attaches to your head this is for brain cancers so the opt to device works with certain brain cancers by pushing the frequency and it's an electrical frequency it's not a frequency like the right frequencies.
The program that the cancer it's just an electrical frequency to change the charge of the cell.
For a couple of reasons that I can explain it to you better fact I do explain it in a blog post so you can look at the blog post about that or opt to dot com.
I looked at that for a long time but I'm pretty sure they have some pretty cool little videos on there too.
The idea is that your cells during replication process your cells go through what's called mitosis where the DNA have to split to opposite sides of the cell in order to duplicate what pushing electrical frequency across them hinders that splitting of the DNA and can slow down replication doesn't kill cancer cells but it can slow down replication.
This device came out about five years ago or so initially got approved only for astro cytomas now I think it's approved for more types different types of brain cancers we've had several patients that have used it you can use this along with your right.
So because this is done people are using this 24 seven they have to shave your head and put this thing out and sticks on your head.
And it doesn't interfere with your right frequencies and your right frequencies don't interfere with this they're completely different modes of operation so question about grounding pads or grounding sheets which is better.
We do have a couple videos on grounding pads and grounding sheets on the members only page so please look at those.
In brief though the grounding pad that comes with your right machine you use with your iron pro way put it on the back on your back while you're doing your iron pro way put it on the chair sit on it partially or lead back on it just helps drive the frequencies through your body.
Grounded sheets of grounding sheets are put on your bed we suggest if you use a grounding sheet you only use it on the lower half of your bed so put it cross ways across your bed if you have a partner's wife husband that sleeps with you so both of you the grounding sheet is underneath the fitted sheet and if it's only on the lower half of the bed then theoretically it will be about your pelvis and then down.
Again, the negative about using a grounding sheet is the full length of the bed is if you're sleeping with the right holding it to your chest and you're on your back well no harm no foul but if you roll on your side in the right bulb balls right onto the sheet you're going to lose some of those frequencies they're going to go towards the ground.
And you'll lose some of those frequencies so that's where I tell people mainly to use the grounding sheets on the lower half of the bed if they use them or don't use them at all so.
I don't like it true right for really big into the grounding sheets and I don't know if he's really big of just to sell another product but I just think through that a little bit differently that he does so that I go through it on that video or detail so remember are to look at the members site for updates and things will try to keep you abreast to do things that are going on in the clinic and.
The idea is that we have a new thoughts all these will be reported and put up there as well so keep looking at the site for new changes updates because we are changing it.
Okay any other questions i got one chat come in here nothing so.
Somebody so they sent a question to the email let's see here is right here all right so i'll just read it to you it says when right protocol is changed by your office and after a few weeks I get what I believe is a herx reaction crippling might be.
We think this is a detox reaction pain is terrible I suspended the right to slow detox is that a good idea can I know i mean.
You know you typically are not going to get a first time a reaction running cancel frequencies so anything is possible no we just haven't seen that so.
I would also investigate other possibilities I mean just because you have cancer doesn't mean that you can't contract live or something like that.
At the same time so make sure you're investigating other possibilities there i don't think the cancer frequencies that we're running in your program are going to cause.
A herxibary action to leave a really really might want to run a line test on you.
That might be a good that might be a thought there the best line test I think out there the most sensitive one is the DNA connections test and I do have a.
I believe I have a blog post on that on our cancer site it might be at my whole for line but contact your liaison that test is not really super cheap but it's a really good test for blind DNA and co infections and it will pick up a few pad line so when you get knee pain that is crippling like that for no apparent reason I have a good idea twisted it.
But that anything like that the first thing you think of is lonely i've seen hundreds of hundreds of line patients we could be wrong but it might be good to look at that maybe it's something's flared it that's a very strong possibility.
But talk to your liaison about that for sure should we put the bulb of the right machine close to our bodies or on top of where the cancer is.
Well hopefully you could do the same thing so if you have a blood cancer like the leukemia or where is the cancer it's all over it's it's a blood based cancer multiple my allowable without any only interference yet it's all over the place then phoma okay now we're talking about a hard cancer so you could put it right over the cancer.
If you have a brain cancer certainly you can put the bulb on the top of your head but it's going to keep you awake so if you hold the bulb close to your tummy close to your chest and you are able to put the covers over it then the bulb will keep you awake at night even if you have brain cancer those frequencies are getting to the brain.
I do have some brain cancer patients that do put the bulb right up by their head and they say oh doesn't keep me awake okay well it's not keeping you awake you closer it is to the cancer the matter.
If you so that's the closer it begins to the cancer the better as long as it's not keeping you awake.
How long after applied black sand do you have to wait to shower or will you have to wear a heggard each time I shower you're not supposed to get it for those who are doing black sand you're not supposed to get it wet.
So if you got it a little damp or you got water out there really no harm but getting it soaked is not appropriate so you're going to have to cover it each time you shower or you're going to have to do something appropriate to keep that away from water so yeah sorry.
Do baths on your back or hands and these do baths on your so this is speaking from a person who's done lots of black backs at black sand and her experience is to keep the sand dry do baths you know instead of showers your back or your knees and hands of these speaking from somebody with a lot of experience.
So very good thank you can a clean liver supplement with no added synthetic iron increase the low red blood cells for people who should not eat animal protein.
Maybe you know clean liver supplements yeah I don't know if they're going to desiccated liver so can desiccated liver help increase red blood cells yeah I can think so your red blood cells are made in your liver.
You make red blood cells at your bone marrow and there are steady desiccated supplements for that maybe desiccated spleen could help but a doubt that liver would help if I test positive for live do you treat that along with curtain pull yes so we would treat that with the right so
It's not uncommon so I could go right along you know can be a causative factor of cancer because it can certainly diminish your immune response because your immune system is it's plummeted by line so you could have had this a long time ago and never do it.
But tell you how many people have had line you know for years and attributed their aches and pains of issues to aging or something else and it was a line or or it's cold infections on and the right is just the absolute best tool for that so yes we just had a program that I just said you a different program.
But yeah, so it is a valuable thing to know to do.
I have pretty sure let me look on my website here for talking.
But I have a DNA connections you might have had to pull them off.
So if you look up just search DNA in the search bar you just start typing DNA in here you'll start CLC the DNA connections DNA line test information and you can click to see a sample report it's a very simple test.
It's a urine test that you do at home too which is kind of nice because we just send you the kit we do not mark up the price of that I think it's $700 that's the problem is it's pricey but all the other line tests are very expensive too and there I think many times less accurate but it's you just write actually we send you the kit and you can write the checkout to the.
The lab as you said didn't get so we're pretty quick getting it back to so it's I think it's a value of a test to know if you've had live past any other questions why kind of a quiet group today why would still smell like mouth balls why would you still smell like mouth balls.
Good question some mock balls are made from that phone.
Um, that's lead is the components of that.
Completed some that's lead here about a kind of carbon found in coal tar crude oil maybe because you're taking charcoal.
Well, let's see 10 H eight that's the bio chemical compounds to and see the latest or general agreed coal tar.
Good question.
It occurs in essential oils of numerous plants.
And they know yeah maybe that's it.
Take it essential oils.
Magnolia is a product in some of our.
I know we have made only several of our products.
That's interesting.
Well, you probably won't have to worry about nice in your calling so that would be a good thing.
That's the most balls out of cabin.
Never had mice could actually have a cabin the next year.
That was a problem.
Could it be parasites or slave got.
Although I don't think so.
I'd never heard of that.
I don't think so.
I would try to correlate it to maybe something you're taking.
Maybe I'll do it that you're taking the essential oil that you're absorbed.
Any possible shortages of supplements due to the threat of upcoming food shortages.
Yes, we don't get free warning of that.
Well, last two years we've had so many back orders and stuff.
It's just insane.
Some companies are much better.
Pre-ordering things than other companies.
I'll tell you biotics research.
I don't know who orders your stuff but they need to get fired.
I'm sorry, but they're horrible.
They have more stuff on back order.
All the time.
get it. In some companies just are really good at keeping things in stock and ordering,
but it gets very frustrating. Frustrating when we, you know, there's things on the back
order. And then some things just go on back order. The college in for more than molecular
went on back order until end of October. It's like this gracious and more than molecular
is typically really good at keeping things in stock. So it's, it's difficult. Nothing that
we know of. So, do you know whether tomorrow will be back to testing? I think they are back
to testing now, but they're being selective. So you're going to have to contact them, say,
are you accepting tests? And I would ask them daily if you could email them. I do know that
I've had some patients send in tests to them and they did get results back. So I just think
that they're so swamped, but I would just keep asking if you can contact them. So this person
says it's but going on sets the cancer diagnosis. I think the smell of mothballs is but going
on sets the cancer diagnosis. I get to investigate that. See if I can figure that out. I'll do
some more research on that and see looking up this cancer. Is this and see for who is this
on? Is this on your on your husband? I'll get a little bit better idea on yourself. Okay.
This person says I did email Navaro. They said, look at the website. The website says no,
they're not accepting right now. Okay. So I'll look up that mothball spell. I'll try to figure
that out. I'm looking forward to the new PEMF docu series coming soon from Dr. Talks. Do you
have any new insights or thoughts on best BEMF machines? I'm ready to invest in the machine, but
want to make sure I make the correct choice. I have different I have different opinions than Dr.
Pollock a little bit, but not really, but he doesn't really talk about cancer. So when I talk to him,
is it, you know, she and I talk on the phone, we have the exact same opinion, but then when you
listen to him talk in general, he's not saying the same thing always. I'm actually in that docu
series interviewed by him. I don't think the interview went really well because he's a little confused
between PEMF and right. He doesn't really fully understand the difference. It's very different. So
PEMF is an electrical frequency. Rife is light frequency and it is 100% completely different PEMF
machines. You could only vary the frequency. You can't vary minutely. You can't change you can't
run a certain hurts on a PEMF device. It's not possible. So because it's an electrical frequency,
it's a totally different wavelength and it's it's just it's a hundred percent different. They're
just two completely different tools and I don't know that he fully understands that. However, he's a great
guy and he if you do buy a machine from him, he has multiple different models that he will say the same
thing that you need a high Gauss output machine. So PEMF machines are rated on the Gauss output
G-A-U-S-S and the Gauss you want a high Gauss output machine for cancer.
So we have a PEMF machine that we have on our website which I think is the best PEMF machine for the
money for the Gauss output for a whole unit. They're still they're expensive. It's about $9,000
but it's it's it goes to about six to 7,000 Gauss and it's not like a like an inclinic unit like
the PEMF machines that we used in our clinical we saw patients in our clinic that I still have.
They are like a 35,000 Gauss output but they also cost you 35,000 dollars. So
on demand is a PEMF machine but it's a very low Gauss output machine. It's fine if you already have a
low Gauss output machine use it it's better than nothing but really if you're looking to buy a PEMF
machine that you haven't spent the money on one yet. You want to buy as high a Gauss output
machine as possible. If you look at our store we have what I think is the best
machine for the money. Now the last time I talked to Dr. Pollock which was about three months ago
he had one similar to that. It's all going to be about the same price because you pay per
basically for the Gauss. But there's a lot of low Gauss output machines that cost the same amount
and they're just a lot of hype. So if you were going to spend the money on a low Gauss output machine
I would tell you to get an IMRS machine. We don't sell those. That's a low Gauss output machine.
They run about 4,000 dollars. If you want to get the better high Gauss output machine
get the one that we have on our store. We have a lot of people that use it and have been happy with it
and we've had one person with one a problem with it. I think it got resolved by the company so
so yeah that's PEMF machines and if you look at our store search PEMF and you'll see
the machine. So if you just look at PEMF on our store you will pull it out. It's called the PEMF
whole unit. You could get it in a carried case tote model or you could get it in a desktop model.
All right any other questions? All right so we'll say goodbye for today. We'll be back next week.
Remember to submit your questions if you can on the member site. It's easier that way to make
sure we catch them and jump on the different Zoom calls and remember that added one. All that's
available. All the links to that are also available on the member site. All right. Bye bye everybody.